let's talk about Antarctica I'm afraid
it's been a week of bad news new
research from Australian scientists says
tourists are threatening the Antarctic
biodiversity with pollution and physical
disturbances more than 40,000 people
actually visit Antarctica every single
year and scientists say even walking on
lost beds will leave footprints that
could last for centuries look I know
this isn't how I'm supposed to react to
that but that really makes me want to
walk on an Antarctic MOSFET which is why
Antarctica is in serious trouble
environmental destruction is not enough
to stop the tide of tourists and morning
shows desperate for unusual travel
segments filler you may not think of
Antarctica as a vacation destination but
apparently that's changing the number
one reason folks say they come on tour
groups to see those human-like
flightless birds
the Penguins tonight and then they cry
when the hell anyway some of the
freshest water you'll probably ever
taste because it dates back 400,000
years what are you doing
tragically the Antarctic ice shelf is
rapidly diminishing now if you'll excuse
me
what so pure what so rare that is the
problem I know we're not supposed to go
to Antarctica but there are free
penguins and snow cones there so they're
going to have to launch a pretty strong
anti tourist campaign all will do it for
them
Antarctica the majestic seven continent
an unspoiled land of incredible ice
formations that you simply have to see
and seeing as how you're looking at them
right now you've technically seen them
so don't come here
seriously you want to feel the bracing
cold on your skin stick your dick in a
freezer you want to see a seal up close
here here's a seal up close now here's a
seal in HD now it's in 3d it's like
you're actually here which hopefully
you're not our point is you don't need
to come here want to impress your
friends by going someplace exotic how
about Belgium and your friends been to
Belgium No then it's exotic to them and
if you simply have to have ice go to
Alaska and tell them you went to
Antarctica they won't know the
difference
hey guess which of these is Alaska you
don't know do you
it's both of them we don't care we're
know
go just so long as it's in this general
area and not here Antarctica stop coming